nous en parlions sur ce plateau la
semaine dernière la mobilisation autour
de la situation au Mali dans le
département des ivelines se poursuit
aujourd'hui c'est Valérie pcrè qui est
conseiller régional elle a appelé le
président de Région Jean-Paul Huchon à
s'engager financièrement 80 % des
Maliens vivantes en France résidant dans
le département et dans la région
Île-de-France elle le précise vient à
communiquer sur place plusieurs
associations sont isé et depuis des
années pas seulement depuis que le
conflit a débuté nous allons en parler
avec Didier wedrago bonsoir à vous vous
êtes chargé de bonsoir à vous vous êtes
chargé de mission pour l'ONG Action
moptit installé à morpa l'ONG qui
intervient depuis 1986 sur place pour un
développement urbain et social
aujourd'hui au regard des avancées du
conflit quels sont les consignes que
vous avez donné sur place aux gens aux
hommes aux femmes qui travaill pour vous
alors écoutez dans au cours donc de la
prise de là nous avons doné le consigs
en réalité donc de fermer notre notre
local centre action à mé et dans le
centre
urbainti alors cette décision a été
prise parce que il fallait sécuriser à
la fois de intellectuel comme aussi les
savariers et suite à à la à la prise de
position française pour repousser donc
les rebelles de Koda
et nous avoons donc compris aussi que il
fallait rester sur C cardes et
effectivement au bout donc de 48 he on
nous avait dit que lesnemi av avait été
rempoussé et que bon nous auons nous
pourrions donc conserver un service
minimum alors vous conservez un service
minimum la liaison avec vous n'est pas
très bonne on va juste vous garder
quelques instants pour savoir si le
travail reprend et et en tout cas si
ensuite vos besoins vont ont déjà aussi
augmenté sur place ne serait-ce que pour
intervenir auprès des populations est-ce
que le travail que vous avez va falloir
le le reprendre à zéro maintenant alors
tout à fait si vous voulez donc les
activités on peut reprendre assez
rapidement et nous avons donc conservé
toutes les activités que nous avions
dans la région sauf bien sûr la zone de
cola où nous avions des activités mais
que nous avons été ob quoi d'accord donc
vous avez progressivement repris et
juste vos besoins est-ce que les besoins
ont augmenté aujourd'hui de par
l'interventionins sont devenus plus
importants parce que nous avons
maintenant chez notre éucation formation
h h des besoins important pour encadrer
les éèves et déplacés et là il y a les
structures ne sont pas assez importante
pour pour les pour pour les recevoir
merci d'avoir été en ligne avec nous je
suis obligé de vous interrompre la
liaison téléphonique n'est pas très très
bonne mais vous nous le disiez pour
cette ONG action m petit les besoins qui
ont forcément augmenté avec des
populations qui se sont déplacées et
qu'il faut accueillir via les
différentes structure que vous avez mise
en place action Mopti basé à morpa qui
intervient depuis les Yvelines depuis 19
186 les coordonnées se sont affichées
nous en reparlerons bien sûr au cours
des prochaines éditions du 78 toujours à
propos de cette mobilisation autour du
Mali sachez qu'attrape le Secours
populaire français organise une soirée
d'improvisation théâtrale le 30 janvier
ce afin de récolter des fonds pour un
programme développé par le Secours
populaire des ivelines depuis un peu
plus d'un an Déclic Théâtre d'ailleurs
dont le président Alain Degois sera avec
nous tout à l'heure pour la sortie de
son livre Medine traap les chiffres de
la sécurité 2012 ont été publiés le
nombre de cambriolage toujours en
augmentation plus 6 % c'est toutefois
moins qu'en 2011 mais les services de
police appellent à la plus grande
vigilance en 2012 tous les indicateurs
sécurité sont au vert en général la
délinquence a baissé 81000 fait ont été
constatés contre 83000 en 2011 seul
ombre au tableau les cambriolages lors
des 12 derniers mois 7567 fait ont été
commis soit une hausse de presque 6 % et
demi une augmentation toutefois
relativisé suite à à l'escalade de 18 %
en 2011 pour lutter contre ce phénomène
les forces de l'ordre travaillent
désormais en commun au sein des cellules
anticambriolage faire un travail
finalement de mutualisation de
l'information avec en plus l'utilisation
grandissante des moyens de la police
scientifique et technique qui nous
permettent de résoudre un certain nombre
d'enquêtes de façon plus rapide et plus
efficace et l'utilisation aussi à chaque
fois que possible des caméras de vidéo
surveillance les voleurs venant le plus
souvent des pays de l'Est s'attaquent
aux zones pavillonnaires en général en
pleine journée les forces de l'ordre ne
peuvent toutefois pas gagner cette
bataille sans l'aide de la population
c'est l'affaire de tous l'affaire de
tous en signalant les choses lesffit que
l'on voit l'affaire de tous en prenant
des mesures des mesures de prévention
qui peuvent être basiques mais encore la
semaine dernière nous a je lisais les
contre-rendu un cambriolage une fenêtre
ouverte au premier étage avec l'échelle
qui était posée à côté al voilà cette
lutte commence à porter ses fruits
puisqu'en 2012 60 % des auteurs de
cambriolage interpellés l'ont été sur un
appel 17 enfin sur le plan plan de la
sécurité routière les Yvelinois
provoquent moins d'accidents mais le
nombre de tués sur la route est passé de
45 à 48 en 2012 dont 17 victimes
utilisateurs de de
rou les vœux à Montini le Bretonneux le
maire Michel logier vient de tenir sa
cérémonie de vœux aux personnalités nous
allons revenir sur les principales
annonces lors de cette soirée avec
Anthony r bonsoir Anthony bonsoir wilfri
alors comme chaque année ça se déroulait
à la Ferme du Manet une Céré mon de vœux
toute somme classique quasiment tous les
maires de la communauté d'agglomération
étaient présents ainsi que François
deasierre député de la circonscription
et forcément il a été question lors de
l'ensemble des cérémonies de vœux d'un
petit mot sur la politique nationale oui
on pouvait pas y échapper les vœux ont
commencé par une petite tirade ironique
du maire Michel Loget logier contre
François Hollande je cite je suis un
maire normal enfin presque normal ma
cravate n'est pas de travers mon épouse
n'a pas de compte Twitter et je ne
change pas d'avis en fonction de mes
interlocuteurs je crois que tout est dit
voilà les vux c'est surtout l'occasion
d'annonce et tout d'abord quelques
quelques annonces concernant les seniors
deux grands deux grands projet en 2013
tout d'abord le relais des seniors qui
devrait ouvrir dans quelques mois ses
portes il sera ouvert à l'heure du
déjeuner dans les locaux de l'ancienne
école Maurice jeunevoie dans le quartier
du village l'autre grand projet c'est la
maison de retraite constituée d'un épad
qui devrait voir le jour dans le château
de La Coudre il serait constitué d'une
partie hébergement pour personnagé
dépendante et d'une résidence service la
décis est à l'heure actuelle entre les
mains du conseil général et de l'agence
régionale santé l'appel à projet a été
publié le 3 janvier un appel à projet
auquel a répondu évidemment la ville de
Montini verdict au printemps et puis une
autre annoncé elle ne fera sans doute
pas plaisir mais c'est habituel aux
habitants de Manil et hameau oui c'est
l'annonce concernant le
CV7 le CV7 ne sera donc pas réouvert
contrairement à la à la à l'enquête qui
avait été mené il y a quelques semaines
qui proposait justement la réouverture
aux voitures en semaine dans le sens
Montini Manil etamoau pour pour souvenir
ce ce chemin vicinal est fermé à la
circulation depuis à peu près 10 ans
c'est c'est c'est la route qui est
derrière la ferme en fait du du Manet en
direction de la vallée de Chevreuse on
va s'intéresser maintenant à plusieurs
chantiers de 2013 oui il y a beaucoup de
chantiers hein sur la commune de de
Montini en ce moment le premier c'est
c'est l'arrivée de Mercedes don dont on
parlait depuis plusieurs mois sur la
commune inimontaine la marque va
installer installer son son siège social
dans le quartier du pas du lac la
première pierre sera posée dans quelques
jours et puis l'autre grand chantier he
qu'on suit particulièrement à TVfil
c'est le Vélodrome à 50 ans en Yveline
édifice que l'on voit grandir jour après
jour la charpente vient d'être installée
et la couverture du toit devait devrait
être finalisée d'ici 3 à qu semaines
l'ensemble sera livré le 13 décembre
prochain et devrait accueillir les
premiers championnats de France de
cyclisme sur piste début 2014 merci
Anthony pour ce point ce qu'il fallait
retenir des vœux du maire de Montini le
brotonux la semaine prochaine nous
reviendrons sur les vœux du maire UMP
des longcours n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez pouvez retrouver l'ensemble de
nos compte-rendus sur les vœux des
principaux élus du secteur sur notre
site internet
tvfil78.com on passe à la culture en ce
23 janvier et c'est Joan assoudri qui va
me rejoindre dans un
instant pour débuter cette chronique
culture vos réactions principales
sorties ciné du jour vos sorties ciné
vos réactions recueillies par Elodie
moine c'était pas mal disons que le
début est un petit peu lent mais bon ça
s nettement vers la fin et puis Nicolas
duvuchel il est assez craquant je
m'attendais à mieux quand même je pense
pas que ça va faire un carton bien aimé
ou c'est c'est gentil quoi dans un
certain sens ça répond un peu aux
questions se on voit comment ça s'est
passé mais après il y a des choses comme
il y a la fiction qui qui a repris le
dessus il y a bien sûr des choses vraies
des choses qu' on dû être un peu aventé
pour adapter le le récit mais
sinon je trouve c'est un assez bon
filmtait bien mais il était un peu long
en fait parce qu'on savait déjà des
événements donc en fait c'est juste basé
sur la psychologie mais il y a pas
beaucoup d'action donc le film est bien
ça reprend bien le fait de la traque ça
c'est vrai que c'est bien ça aurait
peut-être été un petit peu plus long sur
la trque ça aurait été pas plus mal non
plus euh le fait aussi de l'action on
avait vraiment l'impression d'y
être à la culture donc à présent avec
Johanna soudri le temps que vous
récupériez votre votre souffle pour
cette chronique tout à l'heure nous
aurons une large séquence consacrée à la
sortie du livre d'Alain degoua mine
Trapp et puis cette question qu'il pose
pourquoi seuls les enfants de la banlieu
do doivent-ils justifier d'avoir du
talent